Democrats fuming after Republicans
passed a bill to protect women's sports
it would restrict biological males from
competing on female teams the GOP
lawmakers say that it's all about
fairness
if you want to be a transgender that is
that's your right but what about my
rights what about the rights of my
daughters not a single Democrat today
wants to support women in women's sports
we want to protect biological girls
being able to fairly compete against
other biological girls in this Force
they love there's a reason why Title IX
was created there's a reason why there's
men and women sports it's about fairness
so zero Democrats voted for the bill and
the top one claims that the whole thing
is just a made-up issue
in the extreme Mega Republicans are
trying to sensationalize an issue
that doesn't really exist if this is
about Elite Sports competition
let's allow
the relevant organizations
involved in Elite Sports competition
to do what they do
okay Lawrence is that a solution should
it just be left to the Elite Sports
organization so organization by
organization they should decide what
should happen here
absolutely not
I typically stay out of these type of
issues because I say just let people be
do what you want to do
but that's not protecting the women
right here I don't think people should
give a inch on this issue and honestly I
think they're taking the kindness of
Americans as weaknesses
a lot of Americans
believe let people do what they want
with their lives let people go with
bathrooms they want to do and then we
get to hear and we know this is wrong I
mean just for my son we have a young
lady that was just hurt this week
because the ball was spiked at her head
that's going to be a lot of women that
are injured in these Sports because
McNabb let's watch up
allowing biological males to compete
against biological females is dangerous
I may be the first to come before you
with an injury but if this doesn't pass
I won't be the last
this is crazy where are all the women I
mean this is honestly not it's not a man
issue you don't see a bunch of
biological women trying to compete in
men's sports because they know they're
gonna lose but we do see a lot of men
that got their asses handed to them
against other men and they decide
they're going to be the bullies against
the women I can't you know the left
talks about toxic masculinity I can't
see anything more toxic than that
Geraldo what do you think well I think
that it should be simple
without being specific it can be simple
it's about common sense right it's about
how you pick a jury prudent reasonable
normal ordinary
is this
logical is this right
and I think that in this case the
Republicans have the uh the upper hand
because the Democrats are digging in
their heels and creating a situation
where this becomes a Paramount issue and
it overwhelms so many it's so emotional
I mean people are so frightened to get
involved it's not just about you know
everybody's afraid to be called a racist
but the worst worse than racism in a way
is that your anti-trends you're
anti-trans yeah it's ridiculous exactly
so that's now the offense of this uh you
know of these several months right we
roll through these offenses that people
get you know sort of labeled with and
pigeonholed with I don't know what the
next one's going to be Janine but you
know this is clearly the one that is
front and center right now and you know
it's causing injuries and people to say
well what about what about my rights
well you know the the issue before us
right now is not new I mean this started
with the bathrooms what five years ago
you know when they wanted the guys if
they identified as a woman to go into
young girls bathrooms this is about to
me I mean and I have fought for women's
rights from starting the first domestic
violence Bureau in the nation and on
fighting for rape victims Prosecuting
those cases you know and then all of a
sudden there's a hashtag me too and
you're like gee I'm glad you caught up
but then they stopped speaking so it's
more about political ideology than it is
about reality truth and what's fair but
what I see going along this spectrum and
and I was looking up whether or not
Hakeem Jeffries has any daughters that's
what I was on my phone a minute ago but
what I see is that women are being
condemned they are being disavowed they
are being erased and now there are women
that are being used as crash dummies
female crash dummies and I just see it
as almost like the elimination and the
subjugation of women in our society I
don't want a man who doesn't have
breasts to tell me what sports bra I
should wear okay to me that that's
disingenuous do you want a man to tell
you which sports bra you should wear
Greg no I like to go out naturally I
burned my bra in the 70s it was big then
um
it's everything everything's sold is new
again right but it does feel like you
know we were going up it's like oh so
exciting girls had many more Sports to
choose from you know when I was a kid it
was like softball or tennis you know and
and so that expanded but now it's like
each group sort of pushes the group you
know you're no big deal anymore we're
now on to this group this is a a very
funny day in the sense that while this
is going on mayor P mayor Pete is
proposing 20 million dollars for female
Crash Test Dummies and why
why because female bodies are different
he just undermined their entire argument
he just said you know what there are the
average weight the muscle mass vastly
different so there is a legitimate
reason for having different uh Crash
Test Dummies but they can't put how can
you not see this like it's like he just
completely could crushed their idea and
by the way this also proves another
thing how binaryism is biological so
much so that if you come out with a
sensible point of view as as uh as
Ronaldo was saying that the Republicans
just sound like sensible the entire
other side goes against it they don't
even have an argument that he has to say
it doesn't exist and there's this weird
binary mentality that like okay if the
Republicans say only women have uteruses
then we have to say no men can have
uteruses okay so now you've just gone
completely into wacko land but it's
because we have to have one or the other
and what did they do they flipped Title
IX on its head title 9 was supposed to
defend women and the Democrats can't
even defend women anymore and they won't
they won't and they it they are stuck in
this prison of new this prison and they
can't get out of it and they'd rather
just throw women under the bus that's
right the number one voters too yeah
yeah and Biden is say they're not in
right now Biden has promised to veto any
bill that bans males from participating
in people Sports Talk to talk what's
amazing about this topic too when you
talk to people privately who are
liberals and Democrats they agree with
you 100 they don't agree with you when
they're on TV maybe a hundred percent of
men are like this is nuts but they don't
say it because they don't want to get
called names exactly right all right
coming up next the Pentagon drops yet
another mysterious UFO video that's
coming up on the fastest
I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now